From swashbuckling swordplay to supernatural
sorcery, Netflix is a trove of hidden fantasy
treasures just waiting to be discovered.
You may have seen the big titles on the streaming
service, like Pirates of the Caribbean or
Stardust, but that's just the edge of the
map as far as Netflix's fantasy selection
is concerned.
We're heading into uncharted lands to seek
out the best Netflix fantasy films you should
be watching.
Legend of the Naga Pearls
Centuries after an ancient war between two
races, one descendant of the losing race discovers
a way to restore their former glory through
mystical objects known as the Naga Pearls.
That's the start of the action-packed adventure
in Legend of the Naga Pearls, which sees a
common street thief and his CGI animal sidekick
caught in the middle of the battle to take
possession of the mystical objects.
Whoever ends up with them could change the
fate of the world.
If that all sounds convoluted and ridiculous,
don't worry, it is.
But it's also a ton of fun for anyone who
enjoys martial arts fantasy in all its CG-heavy,
wire-fighting beauty.
Cirque du Freak: The Vampire's Assistant
If we're all being honest with ourselves,
Cirque du Freak: The Vampire's Assistant looks
downright horrible.
From that overblown name to a release poster
that looks like a student film parody of Twilight,
there is nothing about this movie that would
entice you to hit "play."
But anyone who does give it a chance is in
for a treat.
With a diverse cast that includes John C.
Reilly, Salma Hayek, Willem Dafoe, and Josh
Hutcherson, The Vampire's Assistant is a bizarre
mix of fantasy, horror, and comedy that offers
one of the more original vampire movies of
late.
"Thank you ladies and gentlemen I am so excited
to be here in this anonymous small town that
used to have character but is now just a bland
suburb filled with chain stores and surrounded
by slums."
After two friends sneak into a traveling freak
show in their hometown, one of them becomes
convinced that one of the performers is a
real vampire.
That fateful night leads to the two friends
joining a secret vampire war.
Even that description sounds terrible, but
Vampire's Assistant pulls it off well enough
to make for a unique viewing experience.
"Here fill that hole."
"I can't do that.
I'm all cramped up.
My legs are still numb."
"Can you feel this?"
"OW!"
Dragonheart: Battle for the Heartfire
Somehow, like the slow creep of a respiratory
infection, the 1996 fantasy adventure movie
Dragonheart quietly became a franchise.
Maybe it's because we live in a magical world,
or maybe it's just because studios love them
some sequels, but there are now four Dragonheart
movies.
"No!"
They all follow the same basic premise: a
dragon shares a heart with a human, and through
their bond they save a kingdom, or something
equally important.
Fortunately, you don't need to catch up on
any of the other sequels to understand what's
happening in 2017's Dragonheart: Battle for
the Heartfire.
This 2017 prequel to the original film sees
a king pass away, leaving his dragon without
a heart-buddy.
It turns out that the king had two estranged
grandchildren, though, who go to war with
each other over the throne.
Add in Patrick Stewart as the voice behind
the dragon, and you'll be surprised just how
much fun you have with it.
"Friends.
I like the sound of that."
Mojin: The Lost Legend
Equal parts archaeological adventure and supernatural
epic, Mojin: The Lost Legend follows three
grave robbers who are hired by a shadowy cult
leader to search for the tomb of an ancient
princess.
To reach the tomb, they'll have to use their
wits to make it through a series of increasingly
dangerous challenges.
You won't find many critics praising Mojin:
The Lost Legend, but don't let that steer
you away.
While the plot may be bare-bones and the characters
fairly one-dimensional, there's a lot of fun
to be had in these underground catacombs as
wave after wave of supernatural terror descends
on our protagonists.
If you get a kick out of archaeologists kung
fu fighting undead demons, you're bound to
have a good time with this movie.
Solomon Kane
The story of a bloodthirsty pirate who turns
to a life of peace after the devil tries to
claim his soul, Solomon Kane is a rare combination
of action, supernatural thrills, and fantasy
that doesn't get too bogged down in the spectacle.
"You can tell your master that I am not yet
ready for hell."
Kane fights hellspawn demons and regular bad
guys in equal measure, but grounds the action
with quieter glimpses into his own struggle
to change his ways.
Critics found plenty to like about the movie,
even if audiences barely gave it a second
glance.
The Monkey King 2
While the first Monkey King is enjoyable,
the sequel is where the story really comes
to life, following the simian deity as he
protects a traveling monk from supernatural
threats.
Don't get us wrong, everything about these
movies is cheesy.
But The Monkey King 2 loads that cheesiness
with better visuals, better pacing, and a
better overall story than its predecessor,
making it a must-watch for anyone looking
for a pure, unrestrained fantasy adventure.
And true to form for these kinds of Chinese
productions, the climactic battle is a visual
jumble of ridiculous CGI that alone makes
this movie worth the price of admission.
And since that admission price is zero to
begin with, what do you have to lose?
Psychokinesis
In just a few short years, director Yeon Sang-ho's
Train to Busan has become a modern zombie
classic.
With that kind of pedigree, you'd think that
his 2018 fantasy-superhero mashup Psychokinesis
would have made more waves, but sadly it slipped
under the current for most people.
When a despondent security guard unknowingly
drinks water tainted by some sort of mystical
meteor juice, he suddenly gains the power
to move things around with his mind.
With his newfound abilities, he sets out to
reconnect with his estranged daughter.
While it takes awhile to get going, Psychokinesis
rewards viewers with an epic finale that makes
the whole journey worthwhile, and proves again
that Yeon is as skilled behind the camera
as he is at writing, heartfelt, emotional
stories.
Vanishing Time: A Boy Who Returned
For a twisted, mind-bending fantasy experience,
look no further than Vanishing Time: A Boy
Who Returned.
This South Korean film opens with five children
who stumble on a mysterious cave deep in the
forest, where they find magical egg at the
bottom of a lake.
According to local legend, the egg holds a
monster that can devour time.
When the kids decide to break open the egg,
they unleash an unexpected supernatural force
that changes each and every one of them.
While the central premise of Vanishing Time
has its basis in fantasy, the story that plays
out afterward is a remarkably gripping drama
about friendship, trust, and betrayal.
It's a quieter, more brutal take on the fantasy
genre, but it's just as gripping as any action-packed
spectacle you're likely to find on Netflix.
Give it a chance and you won't be disappointed.
The Imaginarium of Doctor Parnassus
The story of a traveling troupe of performers
led by a man who's made a bet with the devil
to see who can collect the most souls, The
Imaginarium of Doctor Parnassus is a unique
fantasy adventure that most mainstream audiences
missed in 2009.
Imaginarium straddles a thin line between
magical surrealism and over-the-top goofiness,
but to its credit, it never goes too far in
either direction.
Heath Ledger does a lot to keep the film grounded,
even as it goes deeper and deeper into dreamlike
territory.
If you missed Imaginarium when it was first
released, you should definitely give it a
shot now that it's on Netflix.